what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
what's going on guys this is Rob and
I've been thinking for like the last
week or so I'm running on three hours of
sleep so you guys got to be here with me
here I've been thinking for the last
little while I've seen so many videos
out there where people ask the question
if doomsday fought Hulk who would win
like we do who would who would win that
battle my question is what would happen
if the Incredible Hulk became doomsday
like what would that whole scenario look
like well how would things unfold what
would happen to all of the Earth's
superheroes that's exactly what we're
gonna answer in this video so typically
we would start this off by explaining
who each of these characters are before
we get into a discussion on what would
happen but I'm fairly confident that a
because you found my channel and B you
clicked on this video that you probably
know who the Incredible Hulk is so we're
not gonna spend a whole lot of time
explaining him Incredible Hulk alright
he's the last survivor of Krypton all
right his parents were shot in a dark
alley he went became one of the best
martial artists in the world and he
fights crime dressed as a bat everybody
knows who the Incredible Hulk is alright
it's not confusing at all the Incredible
Hulk
of course is the Incredible Hulk Bruce
Banner turns of the Hulk he's giant he's
green he smashes stuff
however doomsday while not necessarily
that obscure is like a little bit
obscure and that's the funny thing about
this people know doomsday by name but
they don't really know much about do
they they know of him they don't really
know a whole lot you know a whole lot
about him so most anybody who's familiar
with comics is probably watching this
video like I know who doomsday is that's
cool bear with me for the people who
don't so doomsday has been around since
like 1992 and he was essentially just
created because the people at DC had
decided that they wanted to write the
death a Superman but didn't have an
established character that they thought
would make a believable foe capable of
killing Superman so they created a new
character that would be able to take
Superman off the board now like Superman
doomsday comes from the planet of
Krypton but he existed centuries before
the Kryptonian race ever came to
prominence doomsday actually began his
life as a member of a species very
similar to humans being created in a lab
by scientist named Bertrand and what
Bertrand would do was basically take
this child out onto the surface of the
planet and then leave it to die and then
he would basically go back he would grab
the remains he would bring it back into
his lab he would clone the child and
repeat the process over and over and
over again and what does what basically
do is rapidly evolve the child into
something newer and stronger each time
so what is up happening
is that doomsday actually does evolve in
a very unique way and that every time he
dies he would be reborn immune to
whatever had previously killed him so
for instance if you cut off his head
then he would basically resurrect
himself with his head intact and then be
immune to decapitation from that point
forward how he'll be immune to
decapitation I don't know I guess maybe
he would be immune to the material that
decapitated him which means you wouldn't
be able to like cut his neck with steel
you'd have to use something harder no
idea I'm just throwing stuff out there's
comic books take it for what it's worth
now Doomsday's increased evolution has
also resulted in a myriad of other
powers as he has adapted to the harsh
surroundings throughout his many lives
and deaths like super-strength on a
level equal or greater than Superman
limitless stamina and the ability to
survive without food water or air 9
invulnerability and a strong
regenerative healing factor now by this
point you're probably thinking aren't
those pretty much the exact same powers
as the Incredible Hulk
yes those are almost the exact same
powers as the Incredible Hulk doomsday
and Hulk have incredibly similar power
sets which is why so many people want to
see them fight one another but the key
difference here is that Hulk does not
have the ability to adapt his power set
to meet his needs like doomsday does
because of the evolutionary
experimentation done on doomsday he not
only is able to come back to life immune
to what killed him but could also
develop new powers based on the opponent
that he's fighting for example when
doomsday fought Martian Manhunter he
gained the ability to breathe fire due
to Martian man hunters fear of fire so
were the Hulk to become doomsday not
only is he going to have immense
strength durability and healing along
with an infinite level of strength he's
going to be able to adapt to the
strengths and weaknesses of any opponent
he faces so the first thing we have to
do is figure out how the Hulk would
become doomsday and fortunately comics
have provided us with a pretty
convenient solution here with the form
of the doomsday virus so as it turns out
doomsday actually emits spores from his
body that can transforms bosey infect
into beings like doomsday so this makes
the most sense to be the catalyst for
our story as we don't have to come up
with an overly convoluted way for Hulk
to transform into doomsday now I think
if anyone in the Marvel Universe was
going to go about acquiring the doomsday
virus it would be the weapons Plus
program now for those of you guys who
don't know the long and short of this is
that the weapons Plus program is the
program that bonded the adamantium to
Wolverine skeleton and gave Deadpool as
healing factor and ran all sorts of
experiments on people in the hopes of
creating the perfect
Super Soldier if you want a more
in-depth explanation about weapons plus
you go check out my video on the x-men
in phase 1 when we talk about like the
will the Wolverine movie in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe that goes into
probably the most comprehensive
explanation of how the whole weapons
plus weapon X thing works and all that
kind of good stuff but in recent years
and when I say recent years I mean like
within the last year the weapon Plus
program created a hybrid of Hulk and
Wolverine called Weapon H so they
definitely have an interest and using
Hulk to accomplish their own goals so
how I see this going down is that the
Weapon X program kidnaps Bruce Banner
and puts a device on and that keeps him
from turning into the Incredible Hulk
once they have him back at their
headquarters they put him in a
containment cell made of some kind of
unbreakable material and inject him with
the doomsday virus while also taking off
the dampener for vini banner from
hulking out then the inevitable happens
Bruce Banner transforms into the Hulk at
the exact same time the virus begins to
take effect which results and what
everybody who bought the hypothetical
comic came to see a Hulk covered in the
ridiculous bony protrusions that cover
doomsday and of course this doomsday
hawk hybrid quickly breaks out of the
supposed unbreakable cell that he's
being held in and kills all the people
inside the weapon plus compound because
doomsday has literally no chill and has
no regard for human life and then he
sets out on a rampage across the country
we're gonna call him doom Hulk all dude
dude I love that name do Hulk yes do
hawk that's exactly it we're gonna call
him doom Hulk the only alternative is to
call him dunk would you be kind of funny
and I feel like you guys a pick Dolph
just because it sounds funny but I think
doomsday Hulk I think do Hulk is like a
much better name I think that's a much
cooler name so what do you have a huge
Hulk covered in bone protrusions
terrorize in the country it's not going
to be long until the military response
and tries to eliminate the threat but of
course their attempt is in vain as Doom
Hulk is practically impervious to all
their conventional weapons so naturally
anytime conventional weapons fail the
heroes of the Marvel Universe have to
intervene and they immediately know that
things are going to go south really
quickly if they engage the Hulk here as
they are quite familiar with how big of
a threat the Incredible Hulk is and
obviously this is not the normal
Incredible Hulk that they're used to
dealing with so the plan of the heroes
come up with here is that a team is
going to be deployed to face the Hulk
face doom Hulk while another group of
the smartest heroes like Reed Richards
and Tony Stark stay back and try to
figure out a way to take out doom hope
of course the best asset to have in this
scenario would probably be the mind of
Bruce Banner since he's
a genius but obviously understands the
Holker better than anyone else since
like he's the Hulk but unfortunately
he's busy destroying a city as doom hawk
so the rest of the heroes what does have
to figure it out without him now what
we're gonna find out here is that this
is going to go extremely poorly for the
heroes that go out to fight doom hope I
mean not only are they gonna have to
have to contend with his immense
strength speed and durability but
they're gonna find themselves unable to
harm doom Hulk at all and they're gonna
find this out pretty quickly because
they're gonna get rekt I mean like
Wolverine would likely be able to cut
Hulk with his claws within the doomsday
aspect will kick in and it'll adapt
which basically means that Wolverine is
not gonna be able to cut him with
adamantium anymore how that works I
don't know it's comics take it for what
it's worth we're also gonna find out is
that like the Human Torch can blast him
with a supernova level blasts of fire
which are insanely hot innocently
powerful with equal to the temperature
of the Sun if he pushes it far enough
but then dudes they always stand it and
then make himself flame retardants so
everything the heroes throw at doom Hulk
is gonna be completely ineffective and
at this point if we really wanted to go
dark with this story we could
since Doom Hulk would have would like
definitively be able to kill anyone
who's facing him and since this is an
alternate reality continuity story and
since this is my story we could just go
ahead and say that the first wave all
these heroes like Wolverine and Human
Torch of the thing and Luke Cage Captain
America especially Captain freedom we
can just say that they're all gonna meet
their demise at the hands of doom Hulk
he's just gonna kill them all
so stark and Richards because they're so
brilliant and because they just send a
ton of their friends to meet their
demise realize that they're going to
need some really heavy hitters so
they're gonna call in everyone they can
think of like Doctor Strange Thor
Hyperion and even the century to battle
doom Hulk and initially they're gonna
fare better than the first wave of
superheroes but as do hope begins to
adapt to the powers he's able to turn
the tide of battle in his favor pretty
quickly and even take out most of his
opponents leaving only the strongest of
in the century to stand against it now
Stark and Richards come to the grave
realization that something drastic is
gonna have to be done and they decided
that they're going to have to blow the
Hulk up even though their friend Bruce
Banner is inside because he's just going
to be too much they're gonna be too much
death and destruction and nothing else
has been able to slow him down the
problem is they don't want the bomb to
just kill a whole bunch of innocent
people
so Iron Man suits up to join the battle
and leave doom
out over the ocean because he's adapted
his physiology to have the power of
flight by now before Reid destroys a
bomb and then the bomb blows up you know
blows hook up harmlessly over the water
and yadda yadda yadda
so what Ironman gets there centuries
it's kind of like hey man look I'm
really crazy fans hate me because I'm
just like one of the many ripoffs of
Superman they call me a Mary Sue even
though they misuse that phrase all the
time so I believe I should be the one to
take the Incredible Hulk take doom hope
over the ocean and I'll just die with
him and rid the Marvel Universe of my
existence and so Iron Man's like hey man
better you than me and so that's exactly
what happens we end up having the Sentry
fly out over the ocean ah doom Hulk
farlows and then Reed launches this
massive antimatter bomb whatever you
want to call it powerful enough to
destroy doom Hulk which results in both
doom Hulk and Century died and so the
story would end with the heroes being
really upset that the Hulk managed to
kills so many of their friends and
teammates before they were able to take
him out and of course they're upset
because Bruce Banner is basically dead
yet again but hey at least they never
have to worry about doomsday Hulk again
right like do Hulk they don't have to
worry about him except that they do we
know that he'll be coming back and he'll
be immune to the bomb that blew him up
and so the final final panel would show
doom Hulk like voila coming out of the
ocean he'd be all like pissed the bomb
did something to him I like irradiated
him so he would come out looking like
maestro Hulk plus like with all the
doomsday bones or something if you would
look menacing his health like he would
he would look like you just stepped out
of somebody's nightmares Doom Hulk kills
the Marvel Universe that's going to be
the next video that we're gonna make out
of this but that's how I imagined this
story happening that's how I imagined it
going down but let me know what you guys
think down in the comments section if
you are new here - comments explained
make sure you guys are the sub button to
become part of the rod pork you guys
enjoy this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace
you